what if your son wants to be an actor
that's fine he's growing up in LA so
it's good yes both of me his father and
I met on Days of Our Lives playing
boyfriend girlfriend so he was created
through the Arts totally fine if he
wants to do the arts whatever he wants
to do I'm a big believer you can play
every sport do every instrument do every
dance anything and you can go to chemist
camp science camp you can do any of it I
don't care since both of his parents are
artists I almost feel like he's gonna
end up being like a doctor or a lawyer
where me and the dad are gonna pick uh
we can't help you with your homework
because we don't know so yeah he my
parents and support me and love me and
help me in my dream so I can only hope
to be half as good as them with my son
what advice would you give him let's
suppose he's old enough to understand i
know you say he's one now but let's
suppose at 18 he decides he wants to
start acting what advice would you give
him and in terms of I'd say keeping it
real yeah I'd say keep your family the
closest because for me that's what keeps
me alive like having my family and
having that support and i would say that
being in this business is ninety-nine
percent rejection even after you make it
or after you feel like you have
succeeded you're going to have just as
much negativity coming at you as
positivity for your whole life and
there's way too many people's opinions
coming at you and
and now I hope that he'll have a thick
skin and I hope that he'll realize that
the people closest to him are all that
matter and that his opinion on himself
is all that matters and I hope that he
stays true to himself and true to what
he thinks is right and wrong and doesn't
get manipulated or scared or pressured
into going away that will only pull him
down I hope he's happy can someone
develop a thick skin let's say they
don't I mean most artists are pretty
sensitive yeah makes them great so can
someone develop it I think any artist
gets rejected a lot more than people and
notice because they like you go to
auditions constantly in most of its a no
and sometimes you get a yes but that
somebody is literally telling you like
no you're not good enough or you don't
look right or this is wrong with you or
this is wrong with you or like you just
don't fit or this person actually I like
the connection that you didn't like
weirdest things so I think for like yeah
I think you do just naturally start
developing a thicker skin or realizing
that it's out of your control and the
parts that are in your control is the
fact that you work hard you stay focused
you stay true to yourself you stay
healthy and you are the best and honest
you that you can be and if you do that
and at the end of the day if you were
rejected or not or if you book something
you at least know that you're you you're
happy with yourself and you did the best
that you could then everything else is
out of your control and I think that's
the only way to have a thick skin as an
artist is to just know that you're doing
you and that you are trying your best
and that you're bettering yourself in
every way
you